as a private contractor
you possessing a unique set of skills
[Music]
what's that
went up you said it was clear i said the
front was clear
um
front back right wrong
anyway shall we
[Music]
so what we got something rather nasty
has been stolen we have to stop that
getting onto the open market
who's the buyer greg simmons the
billionaire arms dealer
oh a lot very serious faces up here in
there you can't catch this fish with
conventional lures i'm sorry the lure
being daddy francesco
the movie star rick simmons favorite
movie song and how do we get him
blackmail
who's to gear
very good carry on
the world needs you for your greatest
role yet who are you i'm your new
manager
there's a sensitive and awkward
situation between you and your
sister-in-law i actually love my
sister-in-law
it's down to you you made that quite
evident when marimba rhythms start to
play i need to be nervous
no reason to be nervous
they're all the killers
you're an actor
act
okay
i'm ready
let's go to work will someone pinch me
please is that danny francesca what's
next for you i'm playing a mysterious
self-made billionaire
you just described me
shadow maybe do whatever i do
whatever i do whoever greg was buying
from was amongst you last night the
ukrainians
i can get inside the ukrainians
i hope you take them to dinner first
before you get inside of them
sexually
tardy
what happens he recognized your awesome
fortune that is a sexy name cover's
blown we're burnt what do i do the
emergency star is going to melt
[Music]
you stop danny francesca you stopped
great
what are you gonna
so you weren't seen by anyone
yes
that's yes do you want seen by anyone
yes or yes you were seen by someone yes
[Music]
you